the newest projections show that all of
Florida and large areas of Georgia and
South Carolina will see at least
tropical storm-force winds
Miami's mayor is expected to order
evacuations in the city as early as
today
mark Strassmann is in Miami Beach right
on the Atlantic coast with the latest
there mark good morning
good morning this is shaping up as one
of those once-in-a-generation storms
that has everyone's attention here along
Miami's water what could be the most
powerful hurricane to hit Miami since
the devastation of Andrew 25 years ago
many shelves in stores are bare or
picked over across miami-dade and
Broward County there's been a stampede
for food water and plywood lines rings
some gas stations others are sold out
city officials have also warned people
to leave buildings that are near the two
dozen construction cranes around the
city of Miami those cranes are designed
to withstand winds only up to 145 miles
per hour before they could collapse
irma is stronger than that families at
Miami Beach were each given up to 10
sandbags to protect their homes the city
has also installed extra pumps and
generators for possible storm surge but
these are areas in many cases that
regularly flood and of course this could
be an epic storm surge here the mayor
here also a warns people that those
generators and pumps will not work
during a hurricane so all in all this is
shaping up as a red alert for Florida
and Florida governors are rick Scott has
called up all 7,000 members of his
national guard to report for work on
Friday Jeff
mark Strassmann thanks very much